[Music]  basketball camp is next weekend  you got amazing potential on the court  and i can help you get there  that's not what i want dad you never let  me do what i want to do you never let me  just  do me hold up wrong floor  that will smith i gotta deal with this  what in the matrix  [Music]  king hello i am the king of this domain  this is the server verse what you do to  my son where's dom  the only way you're getting your son  back is if you and i play a little  basketball  pete send this clown to the rejects  [Music]  [Applause]  what is this  i'm a cartoon what's up doc  i need to assemble an elite team to help  get my son back i know what you're  looking for  a dream team ma'am shoot the ball  let's try that again shall we  king james  [Music]  you gotta win this game let's end this  and get our son back  yikes  classic welcome to the space  i'm going old school on his butt  [Music]  whoa welcome to the space jam  [Music]  you